[MUSIC PLAYING]
BROOKE BASINGER: My
name is Brooke Basinger.
I'm the technical lead of
a medical device project
at Verily Life Sciences.
And you might wonder
why I'm starting off
my talk that sounds like it
should be about medical devices
with a picture of
a roller coaster.
And it's because I've been a
little bit of a risk taker,
since I was very little.
I remember when I was a
little bit older than what
you see in this
picture, I would go
to this amusement park
in Denver with my family
called Elitch Gardens.
We went every year for a while.
And I wanted so badly to
ride this big, historic
wooden roller coaster.
I looked at it longingly
every year that we went.
And finally, one day, I
was tall enough to ride it.
And the attendant
let me in the line.
I was so excited about this.
I'm sure I was really little.
And as I got closer and closer
to the front of the line,
this thing started to
look bigger, and taller,
and scarier than it really was.
And it started to
sound even scarier.
You could hear this
rattling and rumbling
from the roller coaster.
I would never have
admitted it at the time,
but I think I was
kind of terrified.
But I had set my sights
on this big thing.
I had convinced everybody
to let me do it.
So I couldn't really
back out at that point.
So I just decided to
set aside my nerves.
I decided to ignore them, put
them aside, distract myself
until I got to the
front of the line.
And I sat down in my
seat next to my dad.
And I pulled that lap
bar down on top of me.
And at that point,
I was not just
mentally committed
to this thing,
but I was physically strapped
in, literally strapped in.
I could not get out.
So at that point, you
might as well get on board,
and just roll with whatever
is going to happen,
and enjoy the adventure
that is coming.
So I've used that a lot
through my career as well.
I grew up to be a
mechanical engineer.
I went to a place called
Harvey Mudd College.
It's a pretty awesome place that
deserves an extra shout out.
It is actually one
of those places
that [? Marion ?]
talked about is
getting to be half and half with
female engineers and computer
scientists.
But when I was graduating
from Harvey Mudd,
I should have gotten a
professional, responsible adult
engineering job like all
of my classmates did.
But no.
I had applied for something
called a Thomas J. Watson
Fellowship.
And this Thomas J.
Watson Fellowship,
the intent of this fellowship
is to take students
who are really good at
meeting expectations
and give them the opportunity--
basically pay them--
to run around the world
studying some independent study
project that they make up,
that might be kind of wacky
and off the wall.
And I, of course,
proposed that I
should study international
influences in roller coaster
design.
Because aside from
being a fan, I now
had an engineer's appreciation
for the design challenges
of a roller coaster.
In particular, I
was, and I still
am, really fascinated by the
interaction between the body
and the machine.
How do your design rules change
when you're no longer working
with just metal and plastic?
But now, you actually
have to design
for and around the human
body that grows, and moves,
and changes, and feels,
and breathes, and thinks.
How do you do that?
When you add that human
being into the equation,
it changes everything.
It changes the whole picture.
So maybe it was my nostalgic
stories about Elitch Gardens.
But I somehow convinced
this fellowship committee
to pay me money to travel
around the world riding
roller coasters.
[LAUGHTER]
That sounds like a
pretty sweet deal.
I realize that that
sounds outrageously cool.
And it was.
Trust me.
But it was another
one of these things
that got even more terrifying
as I got closer to it.
Not only was I going to be
outside of the United States
traveling by myself for a whole
year with basically no support;
but on top of that, they
take all these students who
are good at meeting expectations
and pitch them into an area
where there are no expectations.
And that was as scary
to me as the travel was.
But again, I had set my
sights on this big thing.
I had talked somebody
into letting me do it.
So you can't really
back out at that point.
So I got on the plane.
I strapped myself in.
And I ran off around the world
to study roller coaster design.
Mostly, that meant
that I was traveling
for a year with a
backpack and dreadlocks.
But by the end of this year, I
had circumnavigated the globe.
I had ridden a lot
of roller coasters,
despite what you
see in the pictures.
I had built up this confidence
that you could drop me
basically anywhere in the
world, in any situation,
and I might not know the answer.
In fact, I probably
wouldn't know the answer.
But I had the confidence
that I would be fine
because I would figure it out.
I trust my own ability
to adapt and sort out
whatever it is that I land in.
I also had realized by
the end of this year
that the only expectations
of me that matter are mine.
And that's an important one.
I didn't need somebody else
to define for me what it
looked like to do a good job.
I can do that for myself.
And I should do that for myself.
Also by the end of this
year, I had actually
realized that I didn't want
to go into roller coaster
design as a career.
But I was still fascinated
by the interaction
between the body
and the machine.
So instead of putting
the body in the machine,
let's flip that on
its head and put
the machine inside of the body.
So I ended up going
back to grad school.
I got a PhD in biomedical
engineering from USC.
And as part of my
dissertation work,
I worked on this retinal
prosthesis device.
This takes an image from
the patient's eyeglasses.
And it sends it through a couple
of different processing steps
and eventually applies it as a
spatially distributed pattern
of electrical stimulation
directly on the patient's
retina, the back of the eye.
That gives these patients
artificial vision
for people who have
certain types of blindness.
So that's a pretty
amazing thing.
This was a huge
team that did this.
And this is a huge
feat of engineering.
But the pieces that
really hit home for me
were the stories
that our subjects
would tell about how this
impacted their daily lives--
to be able to see something
again, anything again--
how much this meant
to their lives.
There is one patient
in particular
who I remember talking about
how his granddaughter had
been born after he went blind.
And of course, he had talked
to her and interacted with her.
And he could hug her.
But he had never seen her.
And this amazing
feat of engineering,
when he was able to take
it home for the first time,
he was able to take the
glasses portion of it home.
He was able to see
his granddaughter's
face for the first time ever.
So that's pretty cool.
Again, you add that human
being into the equation,
and it changes everything.
Now, I did eventually
grow up and get
a real, professional,
adult engineering job.
I actually did a
couple of jobs in a row
where I was working on
different medical devices
and different types--
different parts of the body.
But I ended up running
product development
at this small company that was
making cannulas, and catheters,
and really complex
medical tubing
that goes into different
types of surgeries.
So this particular cannula
is a really good example
of the types of things
that we worked on.
This cannula takes
deoxygenated blood
from the inferior and
superior vena cava.
Those are the two big veins
that take all of the blood
from your body and pump
it back into your heart.
So it takes that deoxygenated
blood and pumps it out.
And then simultaneously,
through the same tube
and the same incision, pumps
back in oxygenated blood
and spits that back
out into your heart.
That, again, is a
pretty complicated thing
to figure out how to do.
And it's a super complicated
thing to manufacture.
We ran a manufacturing
plant that made this.
And there were plenty
of challenges with that.
But this allows hospitals to
take patients whose lungs don't
work anymore and keep them
alive, for weeks on end
sometimes, while they figure
out how to fix their lungs.
So I was at this company
when what was then
a division of Google X, and
is now Verily Life Sciences,
came calling and
wanted to talk to me.
And to be perfectly honest,
I wasn't actually sure
that I wanted to take the job.
I really enjoyed my life
in southern California.
I was living in Long Beach.
I also was on this very
traditional med device career
path.
I knew exactly where
my career was going.
I knew exactly what
promotion I would get next.
I wasn't sure that I wanted
to flip that all on its head.
And also, I didn't have any
idea that any division of Google
was doing anything remotely
related to medical devices.
To be perfectly honest,
this is kind of all
that I knew about
Silicon Valley.
But true to form, I
decided to get on the ride.
And I am so glad that I did.
I've been at Verily
now for two years.
Our mission is to really
take the world's health
organization, and organize
it, and make it accessible so
that we can use that to help
improve patients' lives.
That's a pretty big, lofty goal.
It's a little hard to
understand, hard to visualize,
what that might look like.
But in the near term,
that means we've
got a lot of concrete
hardware projects
and science and clinical
projects, as well.
We've got lot of
concrete projects
that are moving that
are going to help
us build either
investigational tools
or help us interact
in some patient's
life in a positive
way, maybe in some more
specific targeted way.
And this glucose
monitoring contact lens
is a really good example
of the types of things
that we work on.
If you imagine how
this thing is built,
we take a little
microelectronics ring that
might have an antenna on it.
It would have some
sort of energy storage,
whether that's a
capacitor or a battery--
definitely a custom
designed chip.
And then you sandwich
that between layers
to make it into a
functional contact lens.
Now, I want you to think
about the team of people
that it takes to do
something like this.
You might need an
electrical engineer.
You might need a chip
designer, an antenna engineer.
You definitely need a
mechanical engineer, probably
a polymer chemist.
You might need a biochemist.
You definitely need
a couple of people
working on the glucose sensor.
You might need a process
engineer to scale it up.
You might need a quality team.
You probably need a
regulatory specialist
who can help talk to the FDA.
There are a lot of
functions that go into this.
And I'll let you in
on a little secret.
I am not an expert in
all of those things.
Nobody could be.
But as the technical
lead, it's my job
to not only bring all those
functions to the table,
but make sure that we're
talking to each other,
make sure that we're
speaking the same language,
that we're all pulling
in the same direction
and working together
towards a common end goal.
So that requires of
each of us, myself
included, that we are not
only confident and competent
in the areas that we
own, but that we're not
afraid to say we don't know
certain areas of the project.
I have to get into
areas of the project
all the time that are
things that I don't really
know that well.
But I have to learn, and
I have to adapt as I go.
All of us need to
be willing to be
the beginner in the
room on these topics
that we're not familiar with.
So this picture is a really
good example of that.
This is some of my team
from about six weeks ago.
And what you see in this
picture is an antenna engineer,
a materials scientist,
a mechanical engineer,
and an applied
physicist, all learning
to do eye surgery
for the first time.
I ask my team to stretch
like this every day.
And I also continue to
take risks and put myself
in situations that are
outside of my comfort
zone, outside of
my core competency,
perhaps, things that are a
little nerve wracking, maybe
even a little scary.
But I continue to do that
because I think that that's
how great things happen.
Now, I am wholeheartedly
on board with wherever
this ride is taking me.
And I am definitely
committed to continuing
to take risks and do things that
I find to be scary all the way
until I'm old and gray.
But I wanted to encourage all of
you guys to do the same thing.
Take risks.
Set your sights
on something big.
Talk somebody into
letting you do it.
And then strap yourself in
so that you can't get out.
And at that point, you
have to just be on board
and enjoy the adventure
and see where it takes you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]